Мабуть, багатьом знайома ситуація, коли раптово ламається мобільник. Усі фото, повідомлення, контакти недоступні…
Дідько, коли я востаннє робив резервне копіювання?!
Усе наше життя - на оцих штуковинах. І тому страшно дратує, коли вони ламаються.
Однак таке трапляється повсюдно.
Цікаве у смартфоні те, що в ньому все ламається.
Подивимося, що там усередині…
Невже ці апарати умисно зроблені так, щоб ламатися, аби ми постійно купували нові?
Я гадаю, я… його…
Що, власне, відбувається з усіма зламаними телефонами?
Очевидно, що вони створюють величезні проблеми для довкілля. Але давайте по черзі...
Це старий смартфон. Кілька років тому він віддав душу, акумулятор несправний.
Проте сьогодні, попри мою незграбність, я спробую його відремонтувати.
Я замовив в інтернеті набір для ремонту, за 25 євро.
Ось нова батарейка, яку треба вставити у мобільник.
Є також всі необхідні для цього інструменти. Пінцет…
...присосок, мікроскопічні викрутки, інструкція. Має бути нескладно, чи не так?
Ох, побачимо...
Для початку давайте поглянемо, наскільки ми схиблені на смартфонах. Ми купуємо щороку 1,5 мільярда цих штуковин.
Виробники потирають руки. Існують припущення, що вони, власне, самі штучно й стимулюють цей попит, і ця стратегія зветься…
...планове старіння. Свого часу це вигадали, аби пожвавити економіку під час Великої депресії у США.
Ідея проста: чим швидше ламаються прилади, тим швидше споживачі купують нові. І саме це виробники й зробили: укоротили вік своїх продуктів.
Пружинка у лампочках розжарювання , наприклад, спеціально робилась тоншою, щоб перегоріти вже після однієї тисячі годин, хоч могла б удвічі довше.
Нейлонові панчохи виготовляли так, щоб ті швидше рвалися… Хоча взагалі-то це доволі міцний матеріал.
Речі, які служать один раз і потім викидаються, ідеально пасують виробникам. Адже в такому разі їхня бізнес-модель може функціонувати безкінечно.
Невже зі смартфонами теж так? Невже вони запрограмовані так, щоб швидко зламатися?
Заплановане старіння уявляється, як щось, зроблене спеціально.
Буцімто десь у димовій завісі збираються злі люди: "Ха-ха! Наші продукти через 18 місяців зламаються".
Не знаю, чи справді все так відбувається. Я вважаю, що маркетологи просто кажуть інженерам:
"Цей продукт мусить слугувати не довше, ніж проживе оригінальний акумулятор у ньому".
Погляньмо на Apple. Проти концерну висунули скаргу, оскільки користувачі помітили, що їхні телефони раптом стали працювати повільніше -
після того, як на них встановили новий апдейт.
І справді, у 2017 році Apple визнав це і погодився відшкодувати збитки.
Щоправда, у концерні пояснили, що пригальмували смартфони не для того, щоб люди купували нові, а щоб подовжити їхнє життя.
Цілком може бути, що підприємства так роблять. Однак надзвичайно важко довести такі дії з їхнього боку.
Я хотів поговорити з ними про це і написав трьом найбільшим виробникам, але... жоден з них не відповів…
Але навіть якщо важко довести планове старіння - у виробників є ще інші маркетингові трюки.
Найбільше поліпшення в історії айфону.
Найдосконаліші айфони всіх часів.
Найдосконаліші айфони, які ми колись створювали.
Щоразу, коли з'являється нова модель смартфону, просто кажіть клієнтам: минулорічний апарат - тепер сміття, час купувати новий.
У суспільстві споживання ми здобуваємо статус тим, чим ми володіємо, що ми носимо. Ми презентуємо себе через нашу власність.
Він пасує до будь-якого ритму життя.
Але таке старіння радше психологічне: переконувати людей, що вони потребують новий телефон, хоча старий ще бездоганно працює.
І якщо найновіші тренди цікавлять не всіх і дехто охоче залишив би собі старий апарат- проблема в тому, що їх дуже важко ремонтувати.
Саме від цього мене застерігали.
Коли відкриватимеш корпус, там буде кабель. Краще тримай обома руками, аби не відчинити повністю. Можна лише трохи припідняти…
Все ясно!
Гаразд, я думаю, я… його...
Уяви: ти купуєш автомобіль, а шини замінювати неможливо. Коли шини зносяться, мусиш викинути автівку на смітник і придбати нову.
Ми ж ніколи б на це не пішли, бо це божевілля. Однак саме це відбувається зі смартфонами.
Кабель, який я порвав, мабуть, був не таким важливим. Проте існують інші перешкоди.
Дрібнісінькі шурупи, які викручуються спеціальними викрутками. А найбільший виклик - це...
Так, я думаю, воно приклеєне.
...це вилучити старий акумулятор. Він, виявляється, приклеєний до корпусу.
Робити телефони такими, щоб важко ремонтювалися, - це ще одна стратегія, як змусити людей міняти їх.
Мені здається, вдалося. Виходить... Перемога!
Тепер мушу зібрати все докупи. Між іншим, як тільки ви відкрили прилад - закінчується дія гарантії.
Тож, перш ніж братися за це, треба добре знати що робиш. А не так, як я…
Якось не можу зачинити. Напевно, я неправильно зібрав. Але не хочу тепер зламати. Щось не пасує…
До цього моменту все йшло, власне, добре. Але тепер не можу цю штуку зачинити. Як же це важко! Все, здаюся…
Ой, вже і не вмикається. Я намагався протягом кількох годин, проте так і не зміг замінити акумулятор.
Напевно, відійшов кабель. Можливо, ти неправильно під'єднав дисплей. Нічого, в тебе вийде. А якщо ні, то піди у майстерню, і нехай вони за тебе дороблять.
Або просто викину геть, як це роблять інші. І не лише зі смартфонами.
Ми спостерігаємо значне зростання гір електричного сміття. В усьому світі щорічно продукується 54 мільйони тонн електросміття.
І лише менше 20 відсотків цього сміття вдається переробити на вторсировину.
Решта ж шкодить довкіллю та людям, які це обробляють. Або воно просто лишається лежати у нас вдома.
Багато матеріалу накопичується в наших шухлядах та у підвалах. Це цінні та обмежені ресурси, які не йдуть на повторне виробництво.
У нас культура, естетика викидання речей. Буде дуже важко це змінити.
Виробники кивають на споживачів, споживачі - на виробників… Я думаю, врешті-решт ми всі мусимо стати відповідальними.
Галузь електроніки абсолютно не екологічна, і ми всі в цьому винні. Поліпшити це можливо. І ми просто зобов'язані за це взятися…